so i went there i i was hunting with the
tr
with the warriors i was gathering with
the warriors then they made me queen
and married me to the warrior to the
best warriors
[Music]
sarah begum thank you so much for
joining me all the way from the united
kingdom how are you
i'm good thanks matthias how are you
thanks for having me
thank you very very much for being here
i i really appreciate you taking the
time
uh you know between all the traveling i
don't know how much of that you've been
able to be doing covet but
through all these extraordinary
experiences that you've had uh i'm
especially curious as young entrepreneur
on my journey i'm trying to discover
what are different cultures in the world
what are different experiences people
are having and i can't think of anybody
better
to tell me about these extraordinary
experiences than you
so sarah why am i so excited to speak to
you i'll let you tell i'll let you tell
them
yourself okay um
so i have traveled to um
remote parts of the world living with
indigenous tribes and capturing their
stories
i've also survived dangerous places such
as
the murder capital of the world slums
and mostly undercover to tell those
stories too
so we're gonna have to spend the
majority of the time hearing those
stories because
myself nor my friends have gotten to you
know be undercover in slums and and the
murder
is murder capital of the world so tell
me first a little bit about your your
entrepreneurial
and adventurous self
where does that passion for traveling
and finding those crazy adventures where
does that stem where does that come from
okay so growing up um i was
i grew up in a very multicultural
environment with friends from all over
the world different cultures and i was
always curious
um and i was curious about the world
what else is out there
at the age of nine i learned about
deforestation in the amazon
and it became my dream to go there and
save the trees
and also to visit these tribes
and at the age of 21 i was studying uh
television film and journalism um as a
ba honours at university
but i didn't want to be just another
graduate in a sea of other graduates
i wanted to um stand out from the crowd
and so during my final year i took a
month out to make my own film i won an
award
that helped fund the ticket there i
used my life savings and also
the university's resources take note
and i decided to follow my childhood
dream
um so i found a cameraman from new york
a sound man from portsmouth
and an indigenous tribe who lived
primitively till this day
and i just went there um i planned the
whole thing obviously six months in
advance
and my goal was always to make it a
commercial piece
my goal was also to get it in the cannes
film festival
um so i went there i i was hunting with
the tr
with the warriors i was gathering with
the warriors then they made me queen
and married me to the warrior to the
best warrior
i mean i didn't know what was happening
i was thinking wait a minute
i thought they were just making me queen
because they had to
strip me naked as well and make me one
of them so i became one of the tribe
um and that was actually to create an
alliance so that i would
spread their message about protecting
their land from exploitation because
there's a large oil
reserve where they live and they've had
years of
um fighting against the old companies to
preserve their land
to preserve their land and their jungle
and their home
so when i got back i finished my degree
and then i um i started working in tv
i was taking under the wing of um
prominent film directors and producers
but one of bear grylls directors my role
model bruce parry contacted me that gave
me hope
and then eventually i managed to finish
making this film
this tv style half hour
documentary and i was the youngest
person ever to do that
and to live with a tribe and make a
first film and funny enough as soon as i
made
this film it was accepted into the
cannes film festival
and and that's where it premiered um and
it has been
i'm still making royalties from it today
so
it was um acquired by schwartz tv and
many other
um online broadcasting companies
and yeah talk about following your
dreams right
yeah follow your dreams but that also
made me realize that this is what i want
to do
i didn't realize i was an explorer an
anthropologist
a journalist i had no idea because i
wanted to direct the next godfather
you know and that didn't happen um
it just life just took a different turn
and i wanted to do something meaningful
with purpose in my life
um i just found it so exciting going to
these remote parts of the world learning
about how these people live and
just giving them a voice um and it helps
them it also helps me because
i feel fulfilled um and over the years
that's what i've been doing and jungles
um i've been to the brazilian jungle as
well
in the atlas mountains of morocco with
the native americans in the usa i did a
road trip in three weeks 18 states
on reservations powwows everywhere um in
deserts in the
jordanian desert the wadi ram desert
with the bedmin tribe
and the shy tribe in ghana where i lived
um for a year as an investigative
journalist
a year yeah wait wait i haven't i have
to hear about this
with the tribe in ghana for a year what
is that like
so i lived in ghana for a year as an
investigative journalist
and i was with the shy tribe i was i was
one
the only british um woman at the time
when they were showing me the
and mine festival to commemorate when
the british
um kicked their kicked them out of their
hilltop homes
because they thought they were
committing human sacrifice it was
ah really interesting and they were
called on their ancestors
um and we went to various sacred spots
um
liberation and prayer and chanting and
it was really interesting
really interesting um almost like a
pilgrimage
and so i documented that um
by the way when you when you go and
document as an investigative journalist
so you're both an explorer you
from what it sounds to me it's like you
actually become one of them of their own
right you mean
you marry a warrior right in their in
their in their own ceremony
and make an alliance with them and then
you go and you immerse yourself
in the culture and of the of the shah
tribe and
ghana and spending years and
investigative journalists there but then
also
going to all these different cultures
and so to tell me a little bit about
the submersive experience that you're
that you're having there because
i imagine that you're not just there as
a journalist with a microphone and a
camera all the time right you're
actually experiencing what they're doing
so i don't always like i know that the
camera's there but i'm not focusing on
the camera
when i'm there i'm with them i focus on
them
and it's about human connection so you
have to
connect with them in an authentic way
and i believe by
immersing yourself in a culture but
completely letting go of
any preconceived ideas or beliefs or
values
you get a genuine and true depiction of
their culture and who they are and how
they live
um and that creates understanding
between you
and their culture and then you're able
to portray that in a very honest way
you know and a very genuine way um and i
think
if we all um were able to do that
instead of having all these judgments
about cultures before
experiencing them ourselves and before
communicating with people on a very
honest level you know then
we'll learn how to respect others we can
respect one another and that creates
diplomas
diplomacy and that creates peace
a hundred percent so you're i i i
completely agree i think it starts with
a dialogue before the dialogue it starts
with
respect and and truly respecting and
acknowledging the other person's way of
life which is
different than your way of life yeah but
how can you respect what you don't know
right what you don't understand
you know um so by having an immersive
experience
you learn to understand and by
understanding you then develop
that respect right so before we get to
talking about
you know the different experiences that
you've had i have to hear about you know
being in the slums and and being
undercover also
in the murder capital of the world but
talking a little bit about
but but i have to to hear your your
thoughts a little bit about
impact and at the end you're going
through these immersive experiences and
obviously you're documenting and sharing
them with the world
and one of the one of the insights i
hear from you is in order to really
respect and really acknowledge their
existence and and their you know our our
joint livelihood we first have to
know and understand what the what they
are like
right and it's very hard to do that when
we're not immersing ourselves with them
so how can we
as a civilization come together without
actually
you know without each person being able
to go and immerse themselves with you
know the shy tribe in ghana
watch documentaries um when you see
i mean we live in a country or in a
world where
um we're very lucky to meet people from
other parts of the world
you know our neighbors are different
from us
um our colleagues are different from us
have the time
to maybe ask them questions about their
background about their cultures
you know maybe what kind of music they
listen to and
what would the what was the story of
that artist that they really like
from i don't know from senegal um and
just
learn about them so ask questions that
show that you really actually care about
them
as a person and what's unique about them
because when you ask questions then you
learn
and then you develop that connection and
understanding and who knows it deepens
your friendship or your
working relationship or whatever the
relationship may be
and also watch documentaries read up
about it there's
so many different ways to explore and
understand
and learn without going anywhere
and do you really think that watching
documentaries and exploring online
without having that
personal connection is that enough well
i'm talking about in a pandemic
being in a pandemic you can speak on
zoom
you can interact with people all over
the world on the internet that's why the
internet has been very useful
one thing i'd like to mention about the
internet is
my warriors are on facebook and they
message me all the time
now when they first started calling me
and skyping me
and um sending me email i mean i was
like wow
you molly use the internet this is so
cool but
it's a great way of staying connected to
them
and for them it's a great way of
teaching the world about their culture
and you know sending their message
themselves
it gives them an authentic platform um
so i do think we need to make use of all
the different types of
apps and online education available to
us
however i believe that nothing beats
human connection
so um at the moment i mean
i mean i i don't want to i don't want to
say anything that will make you break
the rules
down rules but after lockdown um
whenever that may be it would be great
for you to
travel and um learn about other cultures
through participation through
observation through experi
experiences and if you can't do that at
the moment
and think about who there is at home
even your friends maybe you haven't
asked them a question that maybe you
didn't think about until now um and if
they're from a different culture or a
different background maybe you can go
and after this after listening to this
ask them
those questions about them maybe you'll
learn something who knows
i i can't wait to go and practice this
myself i've been thinking for a long
time about the things that i want to be
doing and what
one of those things is using technology
to make a positive impact and
and that's on all over the world but
it's but it's very very hard for me to
understand
what really needs to to happen to make a
positive impact
in places like let's say africa or east
asia and
i think part of it is because i'm not
there it's because i'm not feeling the
people i'm not interacting with them
on a daily basis so it's hard for me for
me to understand
really what they need and how we can
collaborate together and i have to also
mention that i've been an avid
participant in burning man and one of
this
one of the main points of burning man is
inclusion diversity and understanding
and it's and there is one rule that you
are not allowed to be a bystander
you're not allowed to be a spectator you
have to participate in whatever you do
so if you see something happening you're
not allowed to stand there and watch you
have to actually go
in the circle and take an active part
and that's one of the scariest
but also most fun things for me in that
but sarah we have about five minutes
left and i'd love to
hear from you some more stories about
your immersive experience because
i want you to give me this taste of of
what i can of what i and my friends can
experience as we
go and travel the world and immerse
ourselves with these where would you
like to go
is there a place in mind you have uh
tell me a little bit about the slums
about you coming from the united kingdom
and immersing yourselves
in a culture that is a little bit
different and
please yeah so um the first time i ended
up in the slums
in uh venezuela was
by accident and this was in caracas it's
the capital
um and pattan is the name of the slums
so patara is the
largest most dangerous slums in all of
latin america
and i ended up there the first time by
accident because the road was
blocked to work the second time i went
undercover
to to explore and
investigate what the conditions were
like there and to learn
how people lived now i remember
i'm seeing a space um
developed by a group of students from
the local university there
they believed by taking care of the
spaces and renovating them people start
caring about sex races
and it reduces crime um and
whilst i was out there i was in these
slum houses
i was invited by a woman who happened to
be a friend of one of the teachers
now it was so bizarre because
i saw like a thousand plushies
everywhere
it was like seven different levels um
in in terms of how many level floors
there were in the house
there were speakers and um like all the
latest gadgets and
tech and you know computers and
music systems everything you can think
of and i was just so confused
um because i was thinking how and they
what they did was that they sold um
essential
goods which in the main city was hard to
find
because of the shortages caused by
economic crisis
um and i couldn't believe i found toilet
paper here and shampoo and
milk and sugar and all these other
things you couldn't find in the shop
in the city so it was like whoa however
they were being
sold about three four five times the
price
really yeah um and
i mean it was just it was just bizarre
like if you watch my
video on my youtube channel surviving
caracas
you'll see and then i do some other like
shorter videos with longer
um longer durations of those actual
scenes
yeah it was just really bizarre but she
was nice to me she offered me some food
and
drank and she was just so crazy she was
really loving so how do you even how do
you even get to those opportunities how
do you go from the uk inside
today i'm gonna hop on a plane and i'm
going to go to venezuela and i'm going
to be in one of the most dangerous
places
in the world so that one actually i was
offered to be
um i was offered a role to be a
journalist and anchor
a news anchor for an english government
channel
based off um and i had no idea what i
signed up for
[Music]
oh uh when i went there um
i discovered i discovered through my um
through realizing the lines that i was
expected to read on tv it was not a true
depiction of what was actually happening
there
wow so i decided to make a documentary
undercover i went back made a
documentary about what was really
happening
and then i um i uh launched that
in december 2015 just before the
elections
um and the slums in ghana that was
interesting
because i did several stories in this
in the slums i did one on petty crime
where a man was
um beaten up back badly it was like
blood flowing down from his head
because he refused to um
fix the car properly uh or he refused to
do something and it was just about
fixing a car
and so he was beaten up and then i just
stopped him and i asked him what
happened and he told me and
i said where are you going and he said
well i'm going to the police station i
said okay can i come with you
it's like okay so as i was walking to
the police station
there was um i i was i was watching him
report the
incident but then a man on a move to
bike
um he was unconscious beaten unconscious
sandwiched between two men on this
motorcycle came and they were trying to
frame the guy who was reporting the
incident
it was bizarre it's like wow what's this
what's going on um and also i went into
uh to investigate the conditions of the
waffles in the slums
and i remember walking up into the
building
and almost falling through the roof well
the floor
you know it wasn't um and
you know these girls they came to the
sydney from the countryside they had big
dreams one of them wanted to be a
football player
because she had talent and she thought
if she goes to the city she can save
that money or she can
be spotted but that never happened she
ended up
in the brothel and she wasn't able to
leave and she was embarrassed to
go back because of because she worries
about what her parents would think
um another one i did was i'm
investigating illegal mining but
i don't really want to talk about that
too much it's like negative inclination
you know
no no i sorry i have to uh first thank
you for being so generous with your time
and for sharing
and all those experiences i think that
one of the things that i'm getting most
inspired by from this is there is
you know the passion and the ambition to
go and experience these for myself it's
one thing hearing
hearing you talk about them i'm sure
it's a completely different world being
there and actually immersing myself and
and and and indulging myself within
those experiences that some of them
sound very uncomfortable
some of them sound scary some of them
sound exciting and joyful
but but but overall i think it just
sounds mind
opening so so thank you for sharing that
with me and thank you for instilling
within me now this excitement
and hopefully anyone else who's
listening but before we leave i have to
ask you the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
okay um adventurous uh
brutally honest that's two words well
there's a hyphen in there
yeah um and
loving i i love to love i believe in
love
a lot i love that sarah thank you very
very much stay safe and stay healthy
and i can't wait to follow you on your
on the next places you're going to go to
the world
and i can't wait to watch these
documentaries because now i'm now
completely
excited about them thank you thank you
so much michael i hope you do
i hope you have fun stories to share
thank you very very much